AUDIENCE: I'm Peter Norvig.
This is Julia Wilkowski.
We're going to talk
to you about how
to make sense of data
coming from online classes.
I think there's a
great opportunity now
we all know of so much more
information being available,
so many opportunities
to take online classes.
But if you're
running one or you're
trying to understand
one, how can
you tell what's working
what's not working?
The first thing you
need is to understand
the data is to be able
to take a look at it.
Last week we had a
great talk at Google
from Mikey D., one of our
site reliability engineers
who went to work on
the healthcare.gov site
and was part of the team
that helped rescue that
from not working to working.
And he reported that the very
first thing he did was say,
we need to have a dashboard.
We need to have big screen
TVs in every room that
says exactly what's
up and what's not.
It's not very
sophisticated, right?
So I could stand
here and lecture you
about complex statistics and
machine learning algorithms
for understanding data.
And yes, there's
a place for that.
But the main part is
just to have the data
and start looking at it.
And the great American
philosopher Yogi Berra
summed that up.
"You can observe a
lot just by watching."
So what can we look at?
Well, here's the
past and the future.
So on the left is
the report that you
get from standard education,
a college transcript.
This has a bandwidth rate of
about 10 bits per semester.
On the right is a mobile device.
This has a bandwidth rate
of 192,000 bits per second.
So that would be more.
You also notice if you've
ever had to pay for college
that the one on the right
is actually cheaper as well.
So how can we take
advantage of all the data
that is now available compared
to the paucity of data
in the past to improve
education continuously?
That's the challenge.
Google's always been a
data driven organization.
So we're comfortable doing that.
I see some of our friends
from Coursera are here.
And they were kind enough to
lend us this dashboard, which
is the simplest
plot you can make,
which is just the
number of users
that are on the site over time.
And from this, you can see
three components superimposed.
One is that there's a startup.
So not everybody
gets going on time.
It takes a couple
days into the class
before people start
to get into it.
Secondly, there is
an exponential decay.
Now, Coursera got
to choose which
class timeline they
wanted to publish.
So this decay is much
less steep than for most
of the classes, which
usually drop off
a lot more of their
students over time.
And the third is these
spikes, this stegosaurus
looking pattern.
Anybody know what
those spikes are for?
Due dates, exactly.
Right.
So some people thought that
they were weekends or something
like that.
If you look at web
logs, yeah, there's
always a weekend pattern.
But these are due dates.
So we've proven that due
dates are, in fact, important.
Here's another dashboard.
This was from one of
the classes I taught.
And this is just each
of the assignments
and the percentage of
people who got it right.
And you go through and mostly
they're doing pretty good.
There's the 80s, 90s percent,
some even on the high 90s.
And then there were two problems
where they're doing really bad.
And that doesn't mean
the students are bad.
That means that we screwed up.
And you have to take a
look at the problems.
And it turns out
one of them, I had
said something kind of ambiguous
in the wording and that tripped
people up.
And the other one,
the TA had written
the wrong regular expression
to grade the examples.
And that screwed up.
But we had this and were
able to fix it quickly,
because we're monitoring
it all the time.
And here's another dashboard.
This is the dashboard
that a student
would get from Google
classroom, which
is one of the products we offer.
But there would also
be a similar dashboard
for the teacher and for the
administrators and so on.
So you just want to be up to
date and know what's going on.
Now let's get into
a little touch
of the more sophisticated
machine learning after we've
driven in this point that
you've got to just pay attention
to the data.
So what this is, is
a graph of states
that students went in,
in submitting programs
for a programming assignment.
And it starts off in the lower
left hand corner in state S,
which is submitting
an empty assignment.
And then you build
up from there.
And the students followed
these various paths.
And each of the circles was
made by clustering together
similar programs by having
an algorithm that figures out
the similarities between
two different programs.
And the size of the circle
is how many of those programs
there are.
And the G1 and the
G2 are two goals.
So there are sort of
two possible solutions
to this assignment.
It was a simple assignment.
So there's really
basically two solutions.
And students converged
along various paths
to get to one of those two.
And most of the student's
made it to one of those goals.
But you also see a
couple states that
were with no paths going
out of them like the state
16 over on the left.
So a small number of students
got stuck in that state.
And so this is was an
automatic clustering algorithm
that gave us this kind of graph.
And now you can use you're
not automated analysis
to go in there and say, hey
what's happening in state 16?
Why are students messing up?
Why are they
getting stuck there?
Why do some students take
this path from eight to 11
to goal two and some other
students take this other path?
It gives you
something to start on
to understand what's
actually going on.
And this is just
one more example,
a little bit more artistic
looking, from this same work.
This is work by some students
at Stanford University.
OK.
Let's have one more example.
So let's say where we have
another programming assignment
and we described the mathematics
of what you're trying to do.
And you write a mathematical
equation like that.
And when you write that, if
you have beginning programmers,
they often try to
translate it literally.
So if you're writing Python
and you took that math
and transliterated
it, that's not
going to be a valid
Python program.
Anybody know what they error
message is going to be?
So it's going to be type error
float object is not callable.
So not a very useful error
message for a beginner.
The reason that happens is
because x was a float number.
And what's going on
there is that this
is syntactically correct.
And it looks like
a function call
where the thing on the
right is the argument.
And the thing on
the left is computed
that should be something
that computes to a function.
But it computes to
a number instead.
so this is a terrible
error message
unless you're an
expert in the language.
But compare that to
what you sometimes
get when you go to Google
and you type in something
and you make a spelling error.
You get something
like, did you mean?
And then we give you a
pretty good suggestion.
And we do that not
because we have
a formal grammar of
English, but because we
have lots and lots
of examples of people
who came before who
typed one thing,
didn't like what they got,
and then typed something else.
Compilers don't have that
corpus of past history.
They just know what the
grammar of the language is.
And they know whatever tricks
the compiler writer put in.
But we can now instrument
compilers to say,
let's take this.
Take all these bad
programs that students
wrote, the mistakes that an
expert would never think of,
and have that as part of
what the compiler knows.
And we could do it for
first-year students.
We could do it for more
experienced students.
We could do it from students
coming from one language
to another language.
And we could even do it for a
particular problem for this one
assignment.
We could say, take all the
last submissions that student's
made, and the errors
that they made,
and build a compiler that
is specialized for that.
We have that capability if
we can collect the data.
Item response theory
is an approach
to understanding
the relationship
between the
difficulty of problems
and the capabilities
of students.
And here we have
students clustered
into bins and the histogram.
So the better students
are on the right.
The worst students
are on the left.
And here's two problems.
The blue problem was
a pretty easy one.
So the best students got 100%.
the worst students
are around 50%.
The red problem is a hard one.
So the best students
are only 60% or so.
And the worst
students are at 20%.
But these are typical
curves for problems.
But now we get a curve
that looks like this.
And this is an indication
that something is wrong.
So what's happening here?
So the best students
are doing better
than the mediocre students.
And they're getting 30% or 40%.
But the bad students are doing
better than the best students.
That's an indication
that something is wrong.
We took this problem,
went in and looked at it.
And we found that there
was, A, an ambiguity
in the wording of the problem.
And B, if you made
a math mistake,
those two mistakes
would cancel out.
And you would get it right.
So the bad students were
getting it right more
than the good students.
And you're only able to discover
that by making this plot
and doing this kind of analysis.
So that gives you
some hint of the types
of things you can do with data.
Now Julia is going to tell you
more specifically about what
we've done with the classes
that we've presented at Google.
JULIA WILKOWSKI: Thanks Peter.
So as Peter mentioned, my
name is Julia Wilkowski.
And I'm one of the instructional
designers at Google.
I've been involved
in six of the MOOCs
that we've launched
to the general public.
And I'm going to give you
a little bit of an overview
about the work that
we've done, what
we've learned from our courses,
and some design applications
for other people
who are thinking
about creating online
courses and helping
the ecosystem evolve.
So I'm going to start out
by asking, how many of you
know what a MOOC is?
Raise your hand.
Great.
I'm seeing about 90% of the
audience raising their hand.
But just for the
other 10%, I'm going
to define the acronym MOOC.
It stands for a massive
open online course.
By massive, we
mean these classes
have had upwards of 150,000
registrants at a time.
By open, we mean that they're
available most likely for free
to anyone with an
internet connection.
They're online meaning
that anyone, again,
with an internet connection
or access to the internet
can access them.
And by course, we imply
some kind of a structure,
a start date, an end date,
some kind of an instructor
or professor who's
involved in the course,
either as a figure in videos
or are able to answer questions
throughout, and a sense of
community where people together
are going through the course
within a similar time frame.
Now I should mention
that Peter actually
hates all of the
words in this acronym.
And I also don't
believe that MOOCs
are the future of
education or they're
going to put universities
out of business.
And Google's role is
we're trying to figure out
what really works well
in online education
so that we can help move
the ecosystem forward.
So about two years
ago, there started
to be more and more of these
online classes from our friends
at Coursera, Udacity, and edX.
And some of us started
to wonder, well,
these courses seem
like they're using
a lot of the similar
tools that Google
has made available for
free to the public.
So we wondered if we
could replicate what
a lot of these other platforms
were doing with Google tools.
Thus, we created Power
Searching with Google,
which was a search
course to teach
the members of
the general public
how to use Google search tools
more efficiently and more
effectively.
We had about 150,000 students
register for this course.
About 40,000 of
them completed it.
And along the way,
we learned a lot.
So here's a brief timeline.
We launched this
course in July of 2012.
Several months later, we
re released the same course
after we fixed a number of bugs.
At the same time, we released
the Course Builder Open Source
code, which powered the
Power Searching Course.
Since that release
almost two years ago,
94 partners have released
their own courses
using this code that we know of.
There may have been other
downloads and releases
that we weren't aware of.
And people are using this
code in many different ways
to launch their own
MOOCs as well as
to implement a flipped classroom
approach where people are using
the infrastructure that
we provide with videos
to assigned videos
before the class
and have their
students come together
in class to have
better discussions
and solve problems together.
We then tried another
class called Advanced Power
Searching.
We launched a course
for web developers
on implementing Web
Accessibility Best Practices.
We launched Mapping With
Google to teach people
how to use Google
Maps and Google
Earth more efficiently and more
effectively about one year ago.
And most recently,
we launched Making
Sense of Online Data
just a few months ago.
So in all of these courses,
I've been involved in some way,
whether it's scripting videos,
writing activities, writing
test questions, figuring out how
the community can help support
each other, and analyzing
a lot of the data that's
coming back from these courses.
So again, to figure
out what works
and what's not working in
these online experiences.
So two of our areas
of research have
centered around scaling
evaluation mechanisms.
And the other one is
about how students,
why students register
for a MOOC and what
we can learn from that.
So the Power Searching course,
again our first course,
was a very traditional
online course,
even though we had
a massive scale
where you watched a video, you
did some activity questions.
You watched another video.
You answered some
more questions.
And at the end, you're presented
with a multiple choice test
to evaluate how well
we felt that you
had achieved those skills.
But advanced Power Searching
was slightly different.
We wanted to teach people
how to solve complex research
challenges using Google tools.
And by complex, we
mean that the problems
had maybe more than one right
answer, more than one right way
to get the answer,
or multiple steps
that you had to achieve
to get the answer.
So we presented
students with a number
of challenges,
which I'll show you
an example in the next slide,
with supplementary videos
and case studies that you
could use if you were really
stuck solving that problem.
For evaluation,
we asked students
to submit case studies of
how they had solved a search
problem related to
their own lives.
Actually we had them submit
two of these followed
by a final challenge, which
we graded by a machine
grading or regular expressions.
So here's an example.
I know the text is hard to read.
But let's say you were hiking
and you saw this feather
on the ground.
And you didn't have
a camera with you.
So you whipped out
your sketch pad.
And you drew a picture of it
so that you could identify it
once you were back
in internet range.
So this is one of the
challenges we presented.
What is this bird?
And if you're really bored
during the rest of this talk,
you can try to figure
this one out as we speak.
So our question was, how
could we effectively evaluate
learners qualitative
work at scale?
We'd already shown that
we could effectively
evaluate multiple choice
questions and short answer
questions.
But we really wanted to
evaluate these case studies.
Because life is more
like a case study
than a multiple choice question.
So we decided to
evaluate or practice
using self-evaluation methods.
And we decided to go
this route instead
of the more traditional,
and traditional in quotes.
Because the MOOC space is
not anything but traditional.
But we decided to use
self-evaluation metrics instead
of peer evaluation for
a couple of reasons.
Some of the research
that we've read
has indicated that people learn
more when they're evaluating
their own work than evaluating
someone else's work.
You're also a little bit more
motivated to evaluate your own
work than someone else's.
And again, some of
the research has
indicated that you have
better metacognition, which
is, you're thinking
about these skills
and you're evaluating
your own work
even after you leave the class.
So for example,
we asked students
to present a case study of how
they solved a complex search
problem.
One of the questions we
asked them to evaluate
was how well they had
evaluated the credibility
of those websites.
So this is because we
want them, when they're
doing a complex search
challenge after the class,
to think about the
credibility of the websites
that they're looking at.
So here is our process.
We had students submit
their case studies.
We gave them a couple of
practice calibration exercises
where we had graded them.
The course staff
had graded them.
They got some feedback
about how well they
were grading these
practice exercises.
Then they evaluated
their own work.
And at the end of course,
we scored a random sample
of assignments.
And we wanted to see how well
the student scores aligned
with our course staff scores.
And here's what we found.
Now ideally, all of
the students' scores
would line up 100%
with the TA scores.
And you'd see every single
dot on that diagonal line.
We didn't quite see that.
But we did see over
half of the assignments
were within one
point of each other.
Again, TA's versus
student scores.
And surprisingly, 73%, or
nearly 3/4 of the assignments,
received at least
a B by the TA's.
So this seemed like it
was a promising start.
But we knew we had
a long way to go.
Now, you may be
wondering, well, what's
to prevent someone from giving
themselves 100% even when they
submitted nothing or poor
work or someone else's work.
And we did see a
little bit of this.
In fact 70% of the assignments
gave themselves full credit.
Not all of them merited
that full credit score.
And of those, 10% were blank.
And another 9% were
duplicate assignments.
So again, this was promising.
But we had some work to do.
So how could we
improve how students
evaluated their own work?
In our next course,
Mapping With Google,
we had students complete
a final project,
which was to create their own
map using Maps Engine Light ,
to tell the story of
some geographical data.
Here's an example
that compares apple
an orange production
in the Americas.
Students were asked to come
up with their own data set.
Or we gave them some
provided data sets
They had to style the points
in some way that told a story.
So again, we had a
very similar process
where students
submitted their work.
They calibrated their work.
They evaluated their own
work after the course closed.
We evaluated a random
sample of those assignments.
And we saw much better
alignment in this class
than the Advanced
Power Searching class.
Again nearly 3/4 where
within two points.
And almost 100% received
at least a B by the TA's.
So what changed
between the first class
and the second class?
Well, a couple of things.
One, in the search
class, we felt
that our criteria
that people were
using to evaluate themselves
were much more subjective
than objective.
So for example, how
well did you evaluate
the credibility of a website is
much more difficult to evaluate
consistently than how many
points are on your map, one
through five for example.
So having that clear
rubric or checklist,
our criteria was, I think,
one of the key factors
that improved our results.
Another key factor was this
last one on our screen.
We ask students how worthwhile
was doing this project.
And in the search class,
just under half of them
said, yes, this is was a
really worthwhile project.
In the mapping,
nearly 3/4 of them
said, yes, this was a
really worthwhile project.
Now the survey scores might
have some self-selection bias.
But I think there's
something here.
But if students find more value
in the work that they've done,
they're going to be much
more likely to grade it
on a more accurate level.
So what does this
mean for people
who are creating online courses
and online course platforms?
We feel that self-evaluation
is an effective evaluation
mechanism for some low
stakes environment.
Now of course, you're not
going to get a job at Google
if you pass our class.
Although some students
did think that.
And I mentioned this in
a research presentation
that I gave on this.
And I made the offhand
comment that well, I'm
not sure I would
want my surgeon going
through a
self-evaluation process.
And one of the
people in the room
said that he actually
had worked with surgeons
and was practicing
self-evaluation with them.
So, I don't know,
maybe it does have
merit in high stakes
environments as well.
We found that it's really
important to test our rubrics
or grading checklists
in advance.
Because I think we
would have uncovered
some of those subjective
versus objective measures.
Also we think that it's really
important to teach students
how to evaluate their own work.
And although we did
it a little bit,
I think there's a lot
of room for improvement
if we really want
to give the students
those metacognitive skills.
So another area of
our research has
focused on how well students
achieve the goals that they
set out to achieve when
they register for a MOOC.
So first question, many of
you knew what a MOOC was.
How many of you
have registered for
a massive open online course?
All right.
I'm seeing about
80% of the hands.
And how many of you
completed that course?
All right.
I'm seeing maybe
20%, which actually
is what we've been
seeing as well.
And if you've read
any press about MOOCs,
you'll see people
saying, MOOCs only
have a 10% completion
rate that's really dismal.
So we wanted to unpack
what this really meant.
So in the Mapping
With Google course,
we had 40,000 registrants and
about 20,000 active students
from all around the world.
And one of our first
questions was, well,
why do people
register for MOOCs?
There are lots of
different reasons.
So our research has differed
from other people's research
in that we're combining
students intent.
We're actually asking them
why are they coming to a MOOC.
And we're doing the
analysis to measure
how well they are
meeting those goals.
So at the beginning of the
course, when they registered,
we asked them up front.
Why are you here?
And was it to earn a
certificate in maps?
Was it to earn a
certificate in Earth?
Was it to earn a combined
certificate in both?
Was it to learn about one or
two new aspects of Google Maps?
two new aspects of Google Earth?
Or were they just
dropping in to see
what this online
course was all about?
So not unlike the
folks in this room,
we found that just
over half of the people
actually intended to
complete the course.
And almost half had no
intention, whatsoever,
of completing the course.
Now if you stop and think
about this from an educator's
perspective, it's
kind of shocking.
As an educator, we
feel like everyone
wants to come and learn
everything that we know
and that we're
going to offer them.
And they have to go through
everything in a linear way,
right?
Wrong.
This data clearly shows
that half of people
had no intention of
reaching the endpoint.
Or that they were redefining
what their endpoint should be,
which I think has huge
implications in how
we design our online courses.
So we did this experiment in
the Web Accessibility Class.
We found something very similar.
Just over half of
people intended
to complete the course.
So our next question
was, OK, well,
people have lots
of varied goals.
How well are they
achieving those goals?
So here was our process.
Again, students, when they
registered, selected the goal.
They interacted with the course
for a 2 and 1/2-week period.
When the course closed, we
extracted the course data
as JSON files.
And then we ran some R scripts
to analyze their behavior.
And here's what we found.
If their goal was to learn
new things or a specific maps
feature, we found that
nearly 2/3 of them
actually achieved that goal.
And the way that we
inferred it was we
said, OK, if they want to
learn a specific maps feature,
we then took the maps
lessons in the course
and we saw, did they
watch at least 90%
of one of the maps videos?
Did they complete one
of the maps activities?
Or did they read the
maps text lesson?
And if any of those
criteria were met,
then we counted them
as achieving that goal.
Even among folks who wanted
to earn a certificate, which
was a much more
rigorous process,
we had between 13% 25% of people
achieving those goals, which
are much more
representative of true life
then if you hear the
statistic only 10% of people
really complete MOOCs.
So we found similar
things in the Intro
to Web Accessibility course.
As a whole in the
mapping course,
we had 42% of people meeting
their goals, Web Accessibility
about half.
And again, what does
this mean for members
of people who are designing
courses or creating
courses or working
on MOOC platforms?
We feel that it's important to
make content available upfront
instead of the
traditional metered way
where the professor
says, OK, week one,
this is what you're
going to learn.
And if you want to
go ahead, you can't.
Because I'm not
releasing the next
set of content until week two.
And if you want to
go ahead, you can't.
Because we're going
to give you the next
set of content the week after.
So what if we could offer
all of the course content
at the beginning and
enable and encourage people
to search for the
pieces that are
relevant and
interesting to them?
What if, when we send out
course emails to students,
we could link to
specific lessons that
are based on their interests
and their backgrounds?
So for example,
you said you wanted
to learn how to navigate from
point A to point B om Maps.
Let's give you a targeted link
in that email that says, hey,
you registered.
You'd said you
wanted to do this.
Here's how you get there.
We're experimenting
with two other elements
of the design, which
is allowing students
to create their
own playlists given
a list of all of
the course content.
So what if we gave them a
list of all of the videos, all
the activities,
all of the lessons,
and all of the final
projects, and allowed students
to pick and choose to create
their own customized course.
Or if we did enough
analysis, we could
offer predicted
learning paths that
says, OK, the students with this
background and this goal tended
to go through the
class in this way.
Then we could offer the
next set of students
those learning paths.
So we're going to
keep experimenting
with many of these elements.
And we're helping the course
builder platform evolve.
And we're hoping that all
of the other MOOC platforms
will evolve.
So that in five
years, MOOCs look
completely different
than they do today.
PETER NORVIG: So I hope we've
been able to tell you something
about how we look at courses,
how we look at the data
we collect, and where
we think it's all going.
And we've got some
time so we can
throw it open for questions.
JULIA WILKOWSKI: And
if you have a question,
please come to one
of the microphones.
There's one in each
of these aisles
so that everyone can hear you.
AUDIENCE: How much
analysis do you
do of the online forum
posts of students?
And have you gained
any insight from those?
JULIA WILKOWSKI: That's
a great question.
And so the question was
about our online forum posts.
And the forum is a
critical way for students
to ask questions and
get questions answered
either by course staff
or by other students.
And we actually haven't done a
lot of sophisticated analysis
on the forum posts.
One, because it's difficult.
And two, because we have
to delete all of the forum
posts 60 days after
the course closed
to comply with our
privacy regulations.
So unfortunately we haven't
done a lot of that analysis yet.
Although Google is funding some
other researchers in cognitive
linguistics to do
some of that research.
So maybe we can report
on that next time.
PETER NORVIG: And I
think it certainly
is important to
monitor the forums
and get a feeling
for what's going on.
You can learn something
just by looking at them
without doing the
sophisticated analysis.
It also is possible to do at
least a sentiment analysis.
So if you're
looking for one bit,
is this positive or negative?
There are classifiers that
will do that pretty well.
But there still are a lot
of privacy issues involved
in what exactly can--
what information can you
keep, how much can you tie
the identity in the forum
to the identity of the student?
Can you tie that to their
identity someplace else?
And I think the
field, as a whole,
has to come to grips
with these privacy issues
so we can share
and learn what we
want without violating privacy.
JULIA WILKOWSKI: A
question over here.
AUDIENCE: So what do you
think about the distinction
between an online course and,
I guess, an online reference?
I work at Udacity and,
you know, a tension
we're struggling
with all the time
is you want lots of
students, of course.
That's a good thing.
But you also, we're a
company full of educators
who want to do really
well for these students.
We want to give
them what they need.
And sometimes what
students think they want
and what we, as educators
and experts in the field
believe they need,
are kind of at odds.
And so this modularity is, it's
hard to incorporate modularity,
or ultramodularity, in that
sort of way of thinking.
PETER NORVIG: Yeah.
Yeah.
I think there is a
lot say about that.
And I think the course
versus reference shows
up and in two places.
One is for the schedule.
Now I showed you that
graph with the spikes.
And that says, if you have a
course with a schedule, boy
that really helps a lot.
That motivates students
to get stuff done.
They know the
deadline is coming up.
They know if they
go into the forum,
everybody's talking about
it at the same time.
And so having a course with a
schedule is useful that way.
On the other hand,
a lot of people
drop out because they
can't meet the schedule.
And they want to work
on their own time.
Or they want to go in
their own direction.
I'd like to have some
kind of a compromise.
I talk about what I call the bus
model where you get on the bus.
There's a schedule, scheduled
stops along the way.
And you work towards those.
But if you want, you
can get off the bus
and wait for the next one.
You may not be able to say,
all right, I want to sign up.
I want to continue tomorrow.
Maybe you have to wait a week.
But at least you don't have
to wait a whole semester.
So I think we want
to work that out.
And then the other
part is, what is
the content that
you want to take?
Should the student be
allowed to pick and choose?
I think we need some
mixed initiative
where the instructor
knows something
about how to put
together a sequence.
But the students also have
their own particular needs.
And we have to figure out a
way to serve both of those.
Did you want to
add to that, Julia?
JULIA WILKOWSKI: No.
PETER NORVIG: OK.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi Peter.
At the top of the
presentation, you
mentioned analytic dashboards.
And I was just
wondering if you've
been using Google
Analytics as a tool
to give a course overview and--
PETER NORVIG: Yeah
AUDIENCE: Some
[INAUDIBLE] breakdown
and that sort of thing.
PETER NORVIG: Yeah.
A lot of people have been
using the Google Analytics.
So this is a tool
that you can track
where people go through a
site from one URL to the next.
Depending on how your
course is set up,
that can be easy to
difficult, right?
So Google Analytics is
designed to track URLs.
You can set it up,
if you work at it,
to track all sorts
of Ajax events.
So you can get very
fine, detailed students
who were on this question.
And then they answered
C on this quiz.
And then they went
someplace else.
Or you can have it more
not as fine grained
if you don't want
to put in the work.
So people have been doing that.
You get some good reports just
by looking at the raw Google
Analytics.
People sometimes feel like
that's not quite enough.
That it was designed for
shopping websites and so on.
And if you really want to get
everything out of the course,
sometimes you have
to take the data out
of the Google Analytics.
And do some separate
processing on it.
JULIA WILKOWSKI: But there
is a course from Google,
from the Google
Analytics team, about how
to use Google Analytics
more effectively.
And they set up these
amazing dashboards.
They didn't look at any of
the Course Builder dashboards.
They just built everything
in Google Analytics
and had some really
interesting findings as well.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Daniel.
I would like to know
if you have looked
at the technical
parameters or if you're
aware of technical parameters
that can predict drop out rates
or how to lower them, either
what kind of video formats
are used.
Or, I myself, ran into a
problem with one of courses
that the volume
wasn't high enough.
And I cranked it up all the way.
I couldn't use it on my phone.
So I just couldn't understand
the guy so actually I gave up.
So is that something
that has been studied?
PETER NORVIG: Yeah.
I don't know how much.
I mean, I think there's
always a lot of factors.
You can go into
the forum and see
what people are
complaining about.
It's sometimes hard to
get the feedback, right?
Because especially the
people who drop out,
you don't hear from them again.
And you can send them
a survey or something.
They tend not to answer those.
So it's sometimes hard to
understand why they do that.
As Julia said, and sometimes
it's they got everything
they wanted out of the class.
So dropping out wasn't
a negative for them.
It was what they intended
to do in the first place.
I think, look at
all the factors,
measure things, see what people
are asking about in the forum,
try to do as much of
post analysis as you can.
If you can get people to answer
surveys, that's really useful.
And use all tools you can.
JULIA WILKOWSKI: We did
send out some surveys
to people who didn't complete
some of our early courses.
And the number one
reason that people
said that they didn't
finish the course
was that they didn't
have enough time.
And it's easy to say, I don't
have enough time for something.
But I think what
that really means
is that they didn't
see the value in making
that extra time for that
course at that time.
Or they had some other
urgent need come up.
But it's easy to say
there's not enough time.
AUDIENCE: But over
time, question
was more from the
other way around.
Did you look at if
it's flash or if people
who use a certain
operating system
have higher or
lower dropout rates.
PETER NORVIG: Right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] four
versus [INAUDIBLE] two.
I don't know, you know,
just some technical stuff?
JULIA WILKOWSKI: We haven't
looked at that data.
PETER NORVIG: Yeah.
JULIA WILKOWSKI: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm also Daniel.
And I got quite intrigued by the
idea of self-selected learning
plans.
Because I've been trying
something like this since 1999.
I have been doing
multiple online courses.
And I found out that
the learning path,
it's like one of these
untouchable cornerstones.
Like both for the
designers of courses.
Like they were able to
compromise from anything.
But the learning path
from ABC, this is mine.
[INAUDIBLE]
And for the students, when
I go into the course, which
was like just the pieces
and let me find my path.
They would feel
kind of confused.
So I'm pretty anxious to hear
some more data on it, some more
experience like what is the
reception of the students?
What is the reception
of the designers?
JULIA WILKOWSKI: Yes.
So I can talk about
some experiments
that we've run in the
Making Sense of Data Course.
And this is actually
interesting.
Because in previous
courses, we'd
seen that people who
do activities actually
have a higher completion rate
than people who just watch
the videos or people
who don't engage
in the content in some way.
So in this course,
we decided let's put
the activities front and center.
Let's encourage them
to do the activities.
And then if they're
stuck, they can go look
at the other content.
And when we did
some user testing,
we actually found that
they hated this model.
People just want to sit.
And they want to absorb videos.
Or that's what
they say at least.
But our data shows
that this isn't
how people really learn best.
So I think when you're
setting up a learning path,
or encouraging people to set
up their own learning paths,
there needs to be some
kind of a scaffolding
where you give them some hints
about what they could choose
or what people like them
have chosen in the past.
Or some kind of a map or maybe
there's five different options.
I think if you just
put it out there
and say, just go create your
own course, some really highly
motivated people who are
already succeeding in MOOCs
will do really well
and will love it.
But for the vast majority
of the population,
I think they'll be hesitant and
not really know where to begin.
AUDIENCE: How about training
designers, the instructors,
how they would
welcome this model?
JULIA WILKOWSKI:
Personally, I love it
as a training
instructional designer.
Because I want people to get
out of the course what they want
to get out of the course and
that it's tailored to them.
Because I think that will
increase the motivation
to complete the course
or meet their own goals.
PETER NORVIG: Yeah.
I know for me in teaching
the I class with Sebastian,
we really felt like
it was flipped.
And we had read about
what Daphne Koller had
done in the flipped classroom.
But we really
flipped our whole way
of thinking about instruction
by saying, rather than thinking
what is it that we have
to say to explain a topic,
we instead thought, what is it
that we want the students to be
able to do.
So we first said, here's a skill
we want the students to have.
We want them to be able to
solve this type of problem.
Then we had to translate
that into, well,
how could we have them
do that problem online
where there's some
limitations and grading.
It's hard and so on.
And then we would
come up with that.
And then we'd design
that exercise.
And only then would we say, now
do we have to open our mouths
and say something?
Right?
And we had to say, now we have
to introduce this problem.
We have to give them
some background.
We have to tell them something.
But if it turned out we
could introduce the problem
without saying anything,
then we would just
go ahead and do that.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm curious about if
you've done any work
on different levels of students?
For example, early childhood
education or high school
students or college students
versus adult education?
And if there are differences
in the kind of recommendations
you would give for designing
an online class in that case.
JULIA WILKOWSKI: Great question.
In all of our
courses, we have seen
similar trends what the broader
MOOC community has found,
which is that the most
likely population to take
MOOCs are well educated,
English speaking Americans who
are between 35 and 45.
So although the promise of MOOCs
is that anyone, anywhere can
take these classes and
become enlightened,
we haven't actually
seen that realized yet.
So unfortunately we've had
a very narrow population
taking our classes so far.
So we haven't done
that kind of analysis
of what's better
for this population
versus that population.
PETER NORVIG: I
think that's right.
Although the way
I think about it
is when you have
such a big audience,
you've got 100,000
people or something,
there's multiple
ways to look at it.
And if you look at
it by majority rules,
then yes, the demographic
that Julia described,
that's the dominant demographic.
They're the early adopters.
So the people that are lining
up to buy the latest tech
toy on the day that
it's announced,
those are the same
ones that are lining up
to take these online classes.
On the other hand, although
the tens of thousands of people
are in that
demographic, there are
people in other demographics
that are spread out.
There is the high
school student.
There is the
Asperger's student who
didn't fit in in a
traditional school.
There's the kid in the
developing world who otherwise
wouldn't have had a chance.
And small numbers of
these are able to succeed.
They're not the majority.
But it's part of it.
And we like to
think about those.
I think these people are
succeeding mostly on their own,
not because of
something we did, right?
So we gave them the opportunity.
But they had to be
exceptional in order
to succeed with
that opportunity.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I had a question on the
differences in platforms.
I think not too
long ago Google said
they would be contributing
to the edX platform.
So I was wondering
if you could speak
to the differences and the
analytic tools between Course
Builder, edX, and
possibly even mooc.org.
PETER NORVIG: Yeah.
So mooc.org is still
a work in progress.
So that's a joint
effort between edX
and Google where it's going
to be sort of the intent
is that will be the long tail.
That edX is primarily
focused on the partner
schools that are part of edX.
And mooc.org will be for
all the other schools.
And we're working
to support that.
But it's got a ways to go yet.
For edX, we work
closely with them.
We do stuff for them.
They do stuff with us.
We worked towards
interoperability.
So we contributed various stuff
like Easy Google Login to them.
And being able to take material
out of our Course Builder
platform and put it into the
edX platform and vice versa.
We're making it all
run back and forth.
We'd like to get
to the point where
the platforms are
merged completely.
But so far it's at the
level of interoperability
rather than merging.
AUDIENCE: I see.
Is there any time frame for
retirement of Course Builder
or is it just--
PETER NORVIG: We don't
have a time frame yet.
You know, it's just there's some
technical issues of basically
the difference between Google
App Engine and the Amazon
Cloud.
And you'd think that that stuff
would just port automatically.
But it doesn't.
There's real work involved.
And it will take time
to work that out.
AUDIENCE: Thanks very much.
AUDIENCE: I work for a
brick and mortar university
and will luckily
and fortunately be
retiring in the next 10 years.
I see a lot of these young
faces in the classroom
who probably are either
pursuing or already
have a traditional
college degree.
Do you see their
children as even
pursuing a traditional
college degree?
Or do you think that the model
is going to completely change
over perhaps the
next generation?
That's more or a
philosophical question
than a logistical question.
But it's really one of those
things I think about sometimes.
I really think everything
shifting and whether 128
credits equals a degree
that will be conferred
on a sheet of paper
from a University.
I don't know if
that's going to be
in existence 30 years from now.
So just kind of a directional,
how do you think this
is going to go.
PETER NORVIG: I'm the
wrong one to predict.
I remember 20 years ago
my daughter was born.
And at the time, there was this
sort of financial instrument
you could buy that was a
hedge against increasing
cost of college.
And I said, no way am I buying
that because in 20 years
everything will be online.
So I was wrong.
But maybe only by
one generation.
But I think what's
more important
than what leads up to
your college degree
is what's after that.
And I think this notion that
you go someplace for four years
and then you get a
certificate and now you
don't have to learn
anything again,
that's clearly
isn't going to work.
That we're going to have to
have continuing education.
You know, you're going to
be educated in one field,
start to have a career in
that, and then that career
is going to be automated away.
And you have to retrain
in some other field.
And that's going to be
more common than it is now.
So we'll see continuing
education, whether it
will be associated with
traditional colleges
or associated with these
online institutions,
it'll be some mix.
And I can't predict
what it will be.
JULIA WILKOWSKI: And it
looks like we are actually
out of time.
So thank you all
for coming today.